joining us now is dr michael michael
ostrohome director
for the center for infectious disease
research and policy at the university of
minnesota
doctor it's good to see you again
morning thank you it's good to be with
you
so let me ask you about what's happening
there in south dakota more than half a
million people are expected to attend
what are your concerns well anytime we
bring a group of people like that
together
they are going to spend time indoors
it's just a matter whether in the bars
the tattoo parlors or the casinos
and as we saw last year with sturges we
actually had a substantial number of
cases tied to sturgis that then were
brought home
to their various states and then we saw
more transmission in those states
from the people who came back from
sturgis so we have every reason to
believe that this year is going to be
uh just as bad if not worse and on top
of it right now as you know
people are really feeling pretty well
done with this virus in many locations
of
the country the fact of the matter is
the virus isn't done with us
we have state fairs that are about to be
held that will bring in two million
people
to various locations we have lots of
festivals that are being held this year
so this is the month i think right now
of these events that are going to
unfortunately occur
at the same time that this virus is
surging let me ask you about
the body administration's plan to
prioritize authorizing a booster shot
for immunocompromised
individuals people wonder when they're
going to be able to get their shots
how soon do you think this should happen
well we have a conflict going on right
now that is normal natural and
unfortunate
and what i mean by that is that just two
days ago the world health organization
put out a plea for a moratorium on any
booster shots around the world
because of the fact countries like ours
that have had two doses available
for virtually everyone whereas of the
6.4 billion people living in
low and middle income countries less
than one to two percent have had access
to vaccine at all
and so the world is asking us not to do
booster shots
inside the country those of those
individuals who are still susceptible
because they haven't had an adequate
response to the first two shots
are begging for their booster shot so
we've got this tension going on i'm not
sure how it will ultimately be decided
someday there's no question in my mind
boosters will be given
and the question is just how soon that
that's going to happen doctor you said
something the other day that got my
attention these are your words this
virus will find you
it will infect you eventually it made
the hair stand up on the back of my neck
because you said it was such
certainty can you elaborate a little bit
on that and why it's so
really scary for children
well gail as you know this virus has
only continued to
become more and more transmissible or
more infectious
over the course of the last 18 months
we've had these mutations occur
and each one of them unfortunately
related to transmissions only made the
virus more infectious
now we have a situation where as you're
seeing you can go for months in a given
location with little activity and then
you see these big surges occur
and what happens people feel like
they're out of the woods you know i keep
telling people
don't think you can run out the game
clock it's not going to happen
ultimately this virus will keep
circulating until it finds you and i
think the story that you had on just
before this one on the forest fire
is basically a one of great similarities
these fi this fire will find that those
trees that force to burn
eventually that's what this virus is
going to do with us as humans
that is frightening that's a visual yeah
it is indeed uh dr michael oscar home
thank you sir appreciate it
thank you very much come